I think last time I played
Aryan in the in the World Cup he was
there with Gary they were hanging out
and they were working together so he was
more of a natural enemy then but now I
mean we're having meals together we're
very good friends also we you know we we
hang out
uh brush at home so it was you know I
didn't want to to necessarily play him
but yeah
um I mean it's not great but it
put some pressure on him
I think he responded pretty okay and we
got this end game with Rook again
tonight which should be should be a draw
I think but it's not so easy
um and um I think yeah he had a lot of a
lot of choices but eventually he went
wrong we see you having dinner with him
tonight with David again in the
restaurant or are you gonna skip this
one no no if you want that I'd love to